Okay.
So let's talk about Heterodox Academy because you set that up,
this organization that you should tell everybody about it precisely to deal with
this issue.
And so I'd like,
I'd like to know about,
about it,
how it's growing,
what it's doing,
what your aims are,
all of that.
Yeah.
So I gave this talk in 2011 laying out the fact that we have no more
conservatives and social psychology and why this makes it hard for us to find
truth.
And,
uh,
in the months after that,
a few social psychologists resonated with the message.
They said,
wow,
I think that,
I think you're right.
I have some data on this.
So the five of us,
six of us,
um,
uh,
wrote this paper.
It came out in behavioral and brain sciences.
Um,
oh,
Charlotte is stern.
I'm sorry,
what's the sixth one that I forgot to add in before?
Um,
we got this paper published and behave and brain sciences.
It came out,
it was sort of online in 2014.
Uh,
but it came out for good in the summer 2015,
which coincidentally was the same summer that my article came out with Greg
Lukey on off of the coddling of the American mind.
That was about things going on with undergrads.
But our concern was entirely faculty.
It was just the nature of the academic community,
the research community.
So we've got these two things going on.
Summer of 2015.
Um,
and then that summer I hear from Nick Rosenkranz,
a law professor who says we had the same problem in law,
lost worse in law.
Well,
it's really bad Canada.
Okay.
Because,
and as he points out,
we're training all these students,
they never meet a conservative.
Then they have to go argue cases in front of judges,
half of whom were appointed by Republicans.
They have no idea what a conservative thinks.
This is malpractice.
We got a train.
So,
and I hear from a sociologist Chris Martins,
same thing in sociology.
So the three of us said,
hey,
you know,
this is a big problem for the whole account.
Have you looked at faculties of education?
Oh,
my job.
Those are the worst by worst.
I don't know the numbers,
but in terms of the vindictiveness that the incredible pressure put on any
nonconforming opinion.
Um,
my impression,
I don't have data,
but my impression from the letters I get is that,
uh,
education schools and social work schools are the worst.
That's exactly in keeping with my,
my understanding as well,
it's hard to tell which of those two or worst,
I would say it's the faculties of education because they have a direct pipeline
to kit and in terms of their effect,
yes,
farmer pernicious.
Yeah,
yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
But,
but equally equally warped let's say,
but,
but more pernicious and the things that are happening in the Canadian education
system as a consequence of that or so reprehensible,
we should get to that because it's happening here too with these ideas filtered
down to high school.
I've been so focused on college now we're discovering the problem is actually
baked in.
The liberal attitudes are often baked in by the time they arrived.
And purposefully,
like in,
in Canada,
increasingly the,
the,
the radical leftists have control over curriculum development and they're
starting to develop social justice curriculums,
which is what they call them for kindergarten kids.
So it's really,
let's finish up with heterodox academy that we'll get back to the earlier
grades.
So a,
so originally three of us decided to put up a website.
I invited all the other authors from the,
the,
the bbs paper.
We invited a few other people working on this.
And so for the first year we had this project,
it was called heterodoxacademy.org uh,
we put the site up on about September 10th,
I think it was 2015 and it was just a community of researchers who are studying
the problem of the lack of viewpoint diversity.
Well,
five days later,
the protest start at Missouri.
So these are racially motivated protest or protest about racial insensitivity
and racial problems at Missouri.
Um,
and at first it seems like this is just a Missouri Prom.
But coming in the wake of course of of Ferguson and all the videos we saw of,
of unarmed black men being killed by police,
the,
a lot of these concerns spread to other universities.
The purchase aren't just about race,
but it was that fall of 2015,
especially the Yale protest.
Uh,
when the president of Yale validates their narrative that Yale's are racist
place,
we have to reform Yale.
Um,
then it spreads nationally and now suddenly this is not just a faculty issue
anymore.
So even though it Heterodox Academy,
we're mostly focused on the faculty,
we're now seeing it's a complex ecosystem with all kinds of forces acting on
universities.
So that between 2015 and 2017,
the danger of speaking honestly about what you think about an academic
intellectual proposition has skyrocketed the risk of being mobbed,
ostracized,
formally investigated by title nine people for Headline People here,
we're sitting here at Nyu,
go to any bathroom.
I'll show you a on this floor,
There's a sign telling students exactly what number to call to report you or me
if we say something that is that someone takes to be a bias act.
Oh,
so you have bias,
you have bias investigation teams here.
That's right.
See,
we haven't gotten to that point,
that particular point in Canada yet.
So I think we're farther ahead down that path in some ways,
but not quite as far and others.
So yeah,
that's really,
that's really unbelievable.
So things are changing very,
very fast.
It's not at all schools.
But then again,
things are changing so fast.
We don't really know.
We don't have good data on what's going on.
What I can tell you though is that at Heterodox Academy,
when we started out in 2015,
there was a lot of suspicion.
A lot of people on the left were afraid like,
oh,
is this some right wing group?
Now,
very few of us are actually on the right.
Um,
but because we end up mostly speaking up for Libertarians and conservatives who
are attacked or silenced,
you know,
people will think,
oh,
we must be right wing,
but we're not.
I mean,
I'm,
I've never voted for a Republican in my life.
I'd never given money to Republican campaign.
Um,
I'm now increasingly calling myself a liberal now that we see illiberalism
flourishing.
Um,
but so when we started out,
there was a lot of suspicion of us from many professors,
but now that it's clear that the problems,
these are not just a few anecdotes.
This is the new normal and it's not just in the university.
So as you pointed out,
that's right.
It's spreading.
And it's not just in the U S it's spread in 2015 I it was uniquely American
problem.
Yeah.
Employee.
It's in Canada and the UK and Australia.
New Zealand.
That's right.
It is a uniquely anglosphere problem.
This is really interesting.
It's not on the continent very much at all.
What about in the Nordic countries?
No,
I mean they have,
so political correctness,
you have lots of places that unique thing that identifies this new culture is
linking the political correctness with the sense of fragility.
And this is something America's pioneered,
the idea of that.
Um,
so the,
in Britain,
they've always had a no platforming.
They call it.
So if there's an end,
there was an Afro British national parties and Actual Fascist party,
you know,
so if,
if a BNP member is going to speak on campus,
you mob him,
you shut it down,
no Plat,
don't give him a platform.
So,
you know,
you've had passionate politics certainly since the 60s.
So that's not new.
And that's everywhere.
Um,
what's newest,
the American idea that if someone says something and it could be a sincerely
expressed idea,
not a racist rant,
just like,
well,
I don't know.
I think that maybe hormones do affect gendered behavior.
Can you say that?
Well,
what if someone takes that as,
as somehow essentially using gender and then saying that women are inferior or
whatever,
if they know what happened to James Damore for exactly.
Exactly.
So,
um,
so that's what's new is the idea that if someone says something that someone,
a member of a protected or marginalized group is offended by,
that person is harmed.
If that person is harmed,
we must protect that person and more ominously just in the last year or two.
It's not just that they're harming their suffering,
it's that this was violence,
violence.
Well,
that's part of the postmodern narratives that
is so dangerous.
The,
the,
the crossing the line into,
into violence.
It just occurred to me,
just like yesterday,
I was thinking about this,
wait,
the state is supposed to have a monopoly on violence,
right?
But if speech,
especially his speech and her speech and the people,
the speech of those people in that academic movement or on the,
and that if their speeches,
violence,
well the state is supposed to have a monopoly on their speech then and um,
and if it's violence,
well then we have a right to use violence back.
The state doesn't have a monopoly on violence cause our violence is,
you know,
more and motivated.
So just the,
the Orwellian and authoritarian implications of this move.
Once you say that speech is violence,
you're unlocking,
you're opening Pandora's box.
I mean,
your,
your five steps down the road to hell.
And I'd say we're about seven steps down the road too.
Okay.
You,
so you're,
you're that concerned about it.